okay i will read the evacuation are down
smooth what's everybody's finished right
should be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the room
by the door to the fire escape staircase
please not both handrails in case the
stairs are wet or slippery w hat flies
today if anyone is able to use the
stairs but they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the
forest back door but they can then be
given assistance our assembly point will
be in public car park at the side of the
Civic street please not delay the
evacuation to collect any belongings and
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff right first of all item is
the pillagers for absence I don't live
there or anything okay non members
attending I don't see here already okay
minutes of the meeting held on the
fifteenth of April is it your wish I
sign them as a true record right matters
referred to the executive and reports
for other committees also I declarations
of interest yes anybody want to declare
any interests racing through this story
right message refer to the executive and
reports from other committees the report
from the view committee and liberation
of the ICT contract so you can go to
that one please right so there are
various recommendations within that
report which we need to speak to
somebody wish to speak to any load
recommend
please I suppose you want me to do Who
am I we shall I 19 de deus as its thank
you I'll go through them one by one I
mean it is as I said a turn group the
other night that really this is such a
waste of time because with what
promotional period of time to run them
on a current contractor we are already
looking at new ways of doing all this
however I will go through them so we've
got litem number one about oh no that's
distraction okay the user surveys are
being stopped if an already stopped time
I believe they have stopped
not to there is no generic profiles to
be used for future installs of software
on the council of iPads the reason that
we have the problem that we have on some
ipads not always to do with people's
password when the passwords were first
installed you didn't realize that
eventually they would have this problem
what happens if you've got the wrong
sort of password get all sorts of apps
pop up out of the blue I in fact one of
the members and a couple of council
meetings ago I don't think anybody would
called hearing it but a thumb kept
ringing and that was coming from his
ally pet because he's at something to do
with phones just popped up out of the
bloody can't stop it but when Andrews
back next wicket is one of the first
things Billy look at and I will be
advising everybody what they have to do
with their password some of you if you
haven't had this happen you've got the
right siege of password but there are
obviously people that
crypto cards I have no idea but why they
think that youth crypto Clause would be
a very good see none whatsoever
everybody's using an iPad since
beginning on but well they fell on one
counselor and I think this is probably
where it's come from quick tell cards
are used within the offices at the
Council because we've had them for a
long time and I still working but quite
frankly is very old-fashioned technology
and let me tell you the most people that
have struggled and struggled hard with
their iPads then I'm try and use a quick
toke off I think I'm pretty good on
technology a tray icon use a future
project to put your password in about
three times standing and not something
that we want to go down that route
anyway right any bill tuning increases
in contracts should possibly be CPI we
can look at that and we will look at it
but frankly we're talking about very
small amount of money cebus does
actually provide a lot more things than
we use it for a normal things I was only
made aware of this very recently and
again it's on my diary this to deal with
one of the good things it does that we
could all use is supplies and rid of
good diary that fits onto the ipad so
you know we will be looking at that and
I think the only young thing they said
was that they want you to every and let
me find it
yes extend the third party review two
contracts costing less than 4,000 found
the amount of money that we would save
on that if any would be well over ridden
by the office of time to do it I think
he'll sorted this stage of the day
really not looking at right now because
again we're looking at a whole new way
of working IT when the contract can be I
think that something jobs or supplies
because that's not online this year
that's a regular reviews looking at
itself sometimes partial sum page 56
let's look at the situation in the new
moon it's all our recommendations and I
don't wanted people to be aware of that
because we don't be doing it no okay if
anybody's lot in questions like the
other woman happy to ask yeah so as far
as I'm looking at the recommendations
that are on page one yes and there's the
six recommendations listed there so the
user survey with the instant photo email
is stopped what do we think I think you
said you it's not that already so
effectively we is that we're agreeing
with that yeah it's happening no generic
proforce be used for future install
software on the council iPads will that
be sold by thing item three the edge of
the various apps in some combine fear so
again
like we can adopt both of those because
effectively they're there you know
agreeing we will be doing to me optional
mission of crypto card i think the
communication from yourself was that's
just not needed there because it's not
something that you would wish on anybody
bill increases the contract well yes
there might be some small savings for us
by these if there are savings to do we
need to look at that yeah I think that's
you know in any contract to the a sonic
you would look at reviews in to think
that the never look at the contract once
again them I can assure you that
constantly look yeah okay so again we
can we can follow that through and I
think it's something that was already
considered in any event and see me
software will clearly that's being
follow through so that could be looked
through and obviously get reports back
on a yes yeah so as far as those
resolutions are concerned are any other
members got any comments on that so
members happy week we take forward
that's offset + that's a recommendation
it's pleasing to you just ask again on
it on 66 it then says at the end
proposes that information resolves to
look a situation again municipal year
and extend the third party review this
is something that we're actually going
to go all ho nervous that's that's down
to review this keep okay no I was like
what I'm nothing if they really want to
you know that's their down to netbook
you know it's how they employ themselves
in their task if you like
okay right go to the next item which is
item 6 which is the customer feedback I
think this is good news looking at this
because we've had far more governments
at link than complaints which is great
complaints for thirty forty four percent
lower than in 1314 as well so from that
point of view you know it seems to be
good news and I think we need to let
people know about this obviously members
please Joe Thank You chairman have just
couple things I would like being
recalled and I did ringtones an
ambulance data and the number of
complaints and fo eyes I'd like to see
if I break down for days IE of perhaps
34 complaints are they the majority from
one person or are they split over five
few people and the same goes with a fair
wise or possibly they're also on the
same exactly the same
you just won't believe the range of
issues yeah but for people my thing
happen from home I rented issue relating
to the airport about noise complaints
and I think something like ninety-five
percent were from one person I think
that's something you need to know that
sort of thing if you like you know is
even so you could actually you know use
the information in context my high
potential so if I can come back as well
see if it needs perhaps one person
perhaps putting in ten freedom of
information is how much does that cost
for us and we should
and also just on our populace whole
fight scenes and paint studies because
they're [ __ ] that's why nice to see
but I think whether you get compliments
all complaints you should always use the
information about those because it
guides to guide you as to where you're
going if you like me the organization
clearly if you're getting complain in
particular direction all the time that
needs to be follow through if you're
getting compliments all the time but all
you actually put in too much resource
into that area and I think you should be
guided accordingly by that I don't know
that now the members have any thoughts
on that but that's my view anyway right
anybody else want sir terry vicinities
the title planning and transportation
yeah needs to be addressed I think
because it's not very helpful did we do
my underwear practical jokes in these
babies thank you okay one other thing I
was asked how this compares with other
councils or similar councils to
ourselves I don't know if you have any
information on that all do we could you
something just have a look at that
perhaps look in our grouping if you like
your councils those are similar to us
and we spindle yeah yes can I mean can
let me do it and just let members know
would that be all right that will be
Terry that will be dawn and I actually
think we do have wreck it certainly
means John chose me to be done in the
park yeah I've got a track them down
ok so now be used alternators okay yeah
we have fun chairman's statistical
neighbors everything perhaps indeed
feels comparison I think that would be
the proper comparison as well yeah okay
anybody else want to speak on this right
have never sat you the recommendation
thank you all right where are we now so
since we nowadays the exclusion yeah I
think